the teaser trailer for it chapter 2 was
recently released and everyone's
starting to get excited for the sequel
here are a few theories I have about
chapter 2 this video was sponsored by
raid shadow legends a theory number one
the fates of Henry Bowers as a child
Henry Bowers is the most feared bully in
town terrorizing the losers club with
his gang of thugs and his switchblade
his mental stability deteriorates
towards the end of the summer when he
kills his father and goes after the
losers club to try to kill them as well
as an adult
Henry plays a significant part in the
book he's broken out of a mental asylum
by hits to seek revenge but in it
chapter one Henry is bested by Mike who
knocks him into the well in the basement
of 29 niebolt which looks to go on
forever
this has led many to believe that the
second film will be taking a different
approach but before I talk about my
thoughts on how Henry might have
survived let me show you how you can
survive in a dark RPG fantasy world with
raid shadow legends dinner is so now I
used to play these types of games on the
computer when I was a kid and I was
honestly pretty amazed so that a mobile
game could have just as good graphics
and be just as immersive as a PC
experience
now I haven't upgraded my phone in a
while but as you can see this runs
completely smooth and it doesn't have a
negative impact on the graphics either
but aside from that this game really
takes the story seriously which is
important to me the boss fights are
these huge epic battles and there are
hundreds of champions in game for you to
collect and customize and on top of that
raids special launch tournament is
happening right now so if you download
raid only through my link in the
description you'll get 50,000 an in-game
silver immediately but the coolest part
is you'll also be entered into their
special launch tournaments where you can
compete with me and other players for
crazy in-game prizes and physical prize
packs we're talking figurines powerbanks
t-shirts and more showing up at your
house so use the link in the description
to download array it today so how did
Henry Bowers survive the fall in the
well house we've already seen that it
has the power to transfigure parts of
the house so I think it stands to reason
that it could have created some kind of
nets or something to catch Henry Henry
had already proven himself a worthy
servant by killing off his father at the
request of penny wise and in a deleted
scene at killing two of his friends
Victor and belch if we take that to be
cannon then it
might not really work for either of them
to be the form that it uses to break
Henry out of the asylum
so maybe Henry never actually left Derry
I think it's kind of a creepy idea to
consider that it's kept Henry down in
the sewers all of those years just
waiting to unleash his minion again 27
years later theory number two we
discover the origin of it in 1990 the
first adaptation of it was released in
the form of a two-part TV miniseries
understandably with a novel coming in at
over 1100 pages some of those scenes had
to be left out one of which was the
smoke hole scene where the members of
the loser Club attempt to carry out an
ancient Native American ritual to help
them decide what they should do about
their Pennywise problem
the ritual involves them starting a
campfire in their underground forts and
breathing in the smoke until they have a
vision telling them what to do if that
sounds familiar you may have already
read the book or maybe you just hung out
with the wrong kids in high school I
don't really know but when they carry
out the ritual everyone jumps out except
for Richie and Mike and they see their
tiny Clubhouse expand and then the smoke
clears and they find themselves in the
middle of the Barrens but the landscape
is different and they're surrounded by
animals that haven't lived in Maine
after thousands of years now I'm not
gonna spoil anything but they basically
see the arrival events the scene takes
place when their kids and it's obviously
not in chapter 1 but just because we
didn't see it in the movie doesn't mean
that it didn't happen we've already seen
in the trailer that there will be
flashbacks to when they were all
children and the majority of the adult
portion of the novel is their Forgotten
childhood memories coming back to them
so I think we could either see a smoke
hole seen as a flashback in chapter 2 or
another scene that explains penny wises
origins based on the trailer it looks
like there's already gonna be some
backstory on penny wisest human form I'm
Bob gray which is the name that penny
wise uses to introduce himself to
several characters in the book such as
Georgie Eddy and Beverly my third theory
pertains to the final form of it now
obviously there's no way I can do this
with argument spoilers so if you haven't
seen the miniseries or read the book
it's a quick enough read isn't it you
can just breeze through that puppy and
uh now our tale so when it comes to the
1990 adaptation the most common
complaint by far is the final
Spyder form it's probably the least
scary part making everything feel a bit
anticlimactic and it's just following
the book but in the book King also is
able to explain that it's not really a
spider and that that's just the closest
thing that our tiny human brains can
interpret a dad's but the response to
the miniseries spider has led some to
believe that filmmakers behind it
Chapter two are gonna take it in a
different direction we have seen them
set up a possible showdown between it
and bill which is known as the ritual of
should in the book where bill is
launched outside his physical body into
this thing called the macro verse where
he basically has to defeat it with his
mind with the guidance of another
celestial being known as the turtle who
is also teased and referenced at in
Chapter 1
[Music]
however unlike the snow call scene it's
not like this is something that could
have happened but it just wasn't shown
in the first movie we see that final
battle and that doesn't happen but what
does happen is anyways temporarily
transforms into a half arachnid creature
while cycling among forms and I have to
think this is a little tease that the
second movie will stay true to the idea
of its final form appearing as a spider
to the loser's however I don't think
that necessarily means that it's going
to be anticlimactic again I just think
that they have to make it cooler looking
arachnid than the one from 1990 maybe
instead of a giant spider it's more of a
half clown half spider alien hybrid I
always thought it was strange that were
haunted by a clown for the whole story
and then at the end it's just a spider
all of a sudden so I think incorporating
the clown into the spider form would be
a more fitting conclusion let me know
what your own theories are in the
comments and click the video on the left
to check out everything you might have
missed in the trailer for each chapter
to remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications check
out rage shadow legends in the
description and I'll see you in the next
one
assuming we both survive
[Music]